- Here's a microphone.
I'm gonna put this under your arm.
- (Mark) All right, Kellie.
Kellie, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I grew up in Queens, New York.
I was born in Brooklyn.
- (Mark) And tell me about your childhood.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- No, I grew up with just my mom.
My dad was in federal prison.
I have four brothers and one sister.
- (Mark) And how was your childhood?
- Oh. My childhood was um,
it wasn't a normal childhood.
I had four brothers who
have had sex with me,
before I even knew what sex was.
I've been in three mental institutions
before the age of eleven.
I came to California at the age of 14.
My father came to New York and got me.
And from there I was
pregnant by my brother.
- (Mark) So you had sex
with all of your brothers?
- All four of my brothers, ongoing.
And I didn't tell anybody
because I was always like the black sheep
of the family,
so me and my mom weren't close.
She was close to her boys,
and that's why I'm real tomboyish today.
So anyway, my father came and got me
at the age of 14
and brought me to California,
but I was pregnant by my brother.
But I didn't know I was pregnant,
and he didn't know I was pregnant.
But I carried real small,
so I never told anybody I was pregnant,
and when he found out I was pregnant,
he left me in an apartment,
and the manager of the
apartment called the police,
'cause she would see me all the time,
and the police came and got me,
and I went to a foster home in Compton.
- (Mark) At what age?
- I was 14 still.
I went to a foster home in Compton.
I had the baby.
I don't know the baby,
but my foster father got me pregnant,
in the foster home.
So I have a boy and a girl,
but I don't know either one of them.
- (Mark) Wow.
At what age did you start having sex?
- Oh. It was early on.
I don't even know the age
because my brothers had started with me.
I don't think they really
knew what they were doing,
but maybe they saw somebody doing it,
but it went on, and on, and on.
One time I was like up here,
looking at my brother
on top of me in the basement.
Yeah.
But anyway, so I had the baby from
my foster father.
I had a girl.
And the little girl actually went
to the foster home that I was in.
So actually her dad was the foster father,
but no one knew,
because we never told anyone.
And from there I went
to another foster home.
They tried to take me to a group home,
I ran away,
and I just kinda been like,
on my own since then you know,
doing what I need to do.
Just to get by.
I've been homeless for 15 years.
Now I have-- they got
me in an SRO over here.
- (Mark) That's awesome.
- And um, that's about how it goes.
You know I've done just what I had to do
to get by.
I've had drug addictions, you know.
But, I've had syphilis,
I've had dis-- you know.
But I just make it the
best way I can make it.
- (Mark) Yeah.
And how old are you now?
- I'm 56 years old.
- (Mark) 56?
- Yes.
- (Mark) And you have two
children, but you don't --
- I don't know them.
- (Mark) You don't know them.
- Yeah.
They are like thirty-something.
The oldest one might be like 38, 36 maybe?
He was born in '77, and
one was born in '78-- '79.
- (Mark) Have you ever--
- Tried to pursue?
No, no.
Because my life is not,
I mean it wasn't together then,
and it's really not together now.
- (Mark) Has it ever been?
- No.
Well, for two years it was.
For two years.
- (Mark) Tell me about those two years.
- I went through a drug program,
the Rena B.,
and I stayed sober for two years.
- (Mark) And how was that?
- That two years was
actually pretty all right.
It was kinda nice.
But, I had a job then.
And the company hired--
It was a cleaning job,
it was janitorial,
but the company that I worked for,
I guess they bid for the company again
or whatever,
and they lost,
so I was getting laid off.
And I just went back to smoking.
- (Mark) Do you ever have contact
with any of your other family?
- (Kellie) I do have family.
I still have four brothers and a mother,
but my family is um...
Everyone is in contact with my mom,
but none of the siblings are in contact
with each other.
So like, if my mom tells me
maybe my brother Damon
is doing this or that,
that's how I know what's going on.
Yeah.
- (Mark) So how do you spend
your day now typically?
- (Kellie) Mostly just um--
- (Mark) Are you using the drugs still?
- (Kellie) That's it.
- (Mark) Crack?
- (Kellie) Yes.
- (Mark) And how do you support yourself?
- (Kellie) Wow. I do whatever I need to do
to support myself.
If it's have sex,
okay, that's cool.
If it's steal something,
you know take--
if somebody's slippin'?
Hey, you know,
that's just how it is, you know.
- (Mark) Yeah.
- (Kellie) So, I don't know.
- (Mark) Wow.
But, looking back at your life,
what do you think was,
what would've changed the
path of your life most?
- (Kellie) What would've
changed the path of my life?
Just, I don't know,
if my childhood you know,
if everything would've just been different
because the way everything
happened is messed up.
And I know it plays--
I got some issues about it.
I really don't know all of them,
but some of them I know.
But I don't really like to
blame it on my childhood,
but really and truly--
because I'm an adult now,
so my childhood is gone, and
I'm still like, fucked up.
- (Mark) Did you ever have a dad?
- I have a father.
My father came and got
me at the age of 14.
- (Mark) Oh that's right.
He came out of prison, right?
- Yeah, he was in federal prison,
but I guess he had been
out of federal prison,
and me and my grandmother,
which is his mother,
my grandmother was always like,
that's my grandmother.
And um.
Wait a minute.
She got in touch with him,
'cause that's her son,
and I guess told him I was having a lot
of problems or whatever,
and so he came.
- (Mark) So maybe the
best years of your life
are those two years where you were clean?
- Yeah those were the most peaceful.
I can remember that peace inside.
Yeah.
It was cool.
- (Mark) What do you see for your future?
Do you see yourself getting clean?
Getting off the street?
I mean I know you're in an SRO,
which is not on the street technically,
but you're still on skid row.
- Um. I don't know if I'll ever get clean.
I've been clean,
I've been to other programs and,
I always kinda look at it like,
if God works it out, then
God works it out, you know.
And that's just how I go.
- (Mark) All right, Kellie.
Well thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Okay.
- (Mark) And good luck with your life
and wherever you go from here.
- Okay. Thank you.